hello everybody my name is Lord Lord do
sonic suggests the game where you as
they have no I hope
[Music]
Oh oh no my falling we're falling we're
still falling oh I guess four okay then
Oh is this just wait how do I do I have
any camera controls do I there just no
point Abby I don't know what's happening
can I actually hit okay can I hit this
thing alright so that works how do i
turn the camera how do i in any way
shape or form
turn the oh I don't okay I don't
oh oh it's beautiful oh it's so
cinematic I'm so beautiful but somehow I
doubt that somehow I really doubt
there's a Hideo Kojima game I really a
sequel the sonic forces okay I get it
oh all right sure
oh no oh hey let go tell them what's
weird about this game as it seems to be
taking itself seriously but not but I
mean it's like it's not taking yourself
seriously but also it's like better made
than just a Garbo Sonic game whoo combo
hello child tails can you get that one
for me thank you I guess wool uh-oh
tails thank you for getting in my way
there tails
get out of my way tails this is my
special tails this is my special boat
there we go
tails god damn it this son we're just
gonna keep going
tails wants to ruin my day and I can't
experience the fun and joy that I've
wanted to get out of this game oh my god
Oh big one see the fingers like I I
honestly have no complaints about the
game at this point I really don't I have
no complaints none at all this is
actually pretty well made the music is a
little grating but a my knuckles is that
you I don't exactly know what happened
to me but I'm gonna assume it all right
way see ya see you around the bend buddy
oh okay all right you can't just was
that spin booba let's do it
knuckles come back knuckles why are you
a dog knuckles why are you walking on
all four it wait did you get what whoa
oh you're better now I guess oh okay all
right well come along come along now
whoa what happens if I do this Oh
oh it's death all right I'm so
completely don't touch the mega screen
spring go to the boss
I've lost I'm coming for you wherever
you are it's gonna be you and me you and
me facing off to the end of days Ju
Eggman Hayek boy get back here yeah I
can't believe it either
how did that plan of yours now work how
am I supposed to and I can I please
catch up to you AG man that far too
excited boy I wasn't getting too excited
to be perfectly honest in fact I was
getting kind of concerned about the the
whole reality of this existence because
it was kind of messed up even before
even before you tricked me with the the
power
[Music]
oh my god Oh kick him while he's down
okay oh good job good job everybody
good job oh so he's dead and you just
throw him into the river
[Music]
Oh Java update wait wait was that in the
game the Java was set in the game I
think that was I think they programmed
that in because it faded out at the
exact same time I'm positive that was
okay all right wow that was that was a
thing of beauty that was honestly a
thing of beauty that was wow that was a
goddamn delight duh-huh
no you have to remember this for the end
of your days you have to remember that
you have to live with the knowledge that
you saw that